[Music]
if you want a life of purpose we can by
inverting the notion that everything
happens for a reason all your efforts
personal professional carnal you must be
willing to make the hard choices do the
unpleasant things risk your most
valuable gases because nothing
worthwhile is ever achieved without
sacrifice
[Music]
now that you're on the brink of
greatness why are there still
limitations to what you'd be willing to
sacrifice in this case a night alone
with your husband would that be an
acceptable condition of a firm offer to
finance your company what do you really
know about a Montgomery
things could get dangerous very quickly
things have always been dangerous
what is it that you imagine I did I made
a mistake I do not deserve to lose
everything
regret is all I felt since the moment we
met how many more people need to be
heard before you get what you want
you're more committed than you realize
[Music]
the worst kind of victim is the one that
chooses to create another
[Music]
are you absolutely certain this is the
choice you want to make I'm not what you
think I am maybe not now I'm beginning
to see potential
[Music]
success comes at a cost
[Music]
[Music]